the title kind of gives it away we're
talking about handling of external
clinical information in small Primary
Care practices so we're going to focus
on that area and Define our terms even
more but a little bit about the big wave
a lot of people have talked about the
Tsunami of information that's
overwhelming uh all clinicians
provides of electronic paper and all
sorts of forms so this is just kind of a
nice reminder of what small practices
are having to deal with in terms of this
onslaught of information
so it's not just me that thinks that
though I was really struck in fact one
of The Inspirations for this work was
the paper by John Beasley at Allen
keeping several human factors people in
my life
that term this information chaos and in
the beastly people they talk about five
different types of information hazards
if you will that affect Primary Care
means include just too much information
missing or incomplete information
fragmentation and siloing that we all
know about conflicting information and
information that's just plain wrong and
in the paper they say that these can
lead to not only cognitive overload or
conditions but also a loss of
situational awareness
and because a lot of my perspective
comes from reading a chemical factors
and working with Dr Park at Oregon State
situational awareness really struck me
so with that theme will come up a couple
times today
so that was the inspiration as part of
the dissertation though there was a
liberty and that liver view included 89
papers that broke out basically in the
three categories uh the first category
was on work practices what are people
doing in small practices it's not just a
hand lab results although that was the
vast majority of the papers but also
referral reports discharge summaries and
Mission notifications anything that I'm
lumping into the category external
clinical information
but as I say most of these WordPress
papers focused on laboratory tests are
or Radiology tests
information hazards there was a laundry
list of information hazards basically
again information could be missing when
it was needed diagnosis or follow-up
would be absent handling steps reporting
documented in fact several of these
studies looked at how well handling
steps were logged in initials placed on
pieces of paper sign offs done in
electronic health sectors and the
documentation was very poor now whether
that means the practices were also
formed is the subject of discussion
and then finally tracking the requests
is largely an analytic period and then
finally the interventions what has been
proposed to solve this well as you'd
expect health information technology has
been leading one and the vast majority
of papers were on electronic health
records for managing these types of
information again mainly test results
and they pointed out that hybrid systems
systems that included both paper
elements as well as electronic health
records performed less well than either
a fully paper or a fully electronic
system this idea of having different
workflows for different media seem to
there seems to be evidence that that
makes things worse
so that's literature in normal lighting
and a research question I wanted to look
at the socio-technical system so not
just the workflowing people not just
what they do but why they do it and how
they interact with each other to do
those things so as you can see the
research question what socio-technical
factors shape how small Primary Care
practices handle experimental
information and we'll Define those terms
a little bit more
and I divided that up into three
specific games
the first is simply to describe not only
the work but the context in which that
work takes place
centered to compare the factors that
shape those word practices and third to
try to identify implications for
designers not just designers of
Information Technology but designers of
process and process Improvement so what
can we learn from these practices
so some definitions very quickly I
already defined external clinical
information keep in mind that I'm
including not just test results coming
in from outside Laboratories but also
referral reports discharge summaries
anything that's patient specific plan
and comes from an outside source so
that's the influence side of our system
diagram here on the right hand side
we have primary care and there are many
definitions of what primary care is but
I had to Define that for the purposes of
the study and I chose part of a
starfield's definition with basically
four pillars of primary care now again
this is subject to discussion is what
the best definition might be but it
allowed me to say what do I think
primarily care is
first Contact
longitudinal comprehensive learning so
that really shaped how I Define my terms
and then in the center we have the
processes themselves input output
process a socio-technical system that
actually transforms information into if
not knowledge into clinical action
and then finally down below we have the
impact of the external environment on
those processes so again those of you
who know general assistance Theory this
is a very simplified version of a
systems diagram but that's the
conceptual model that really guided this
work my focus of course was in the
middle here and also the external
constraints
so how did we decide to do it well we
broke the three aims down into
individual stages of the site
the first part of the study was a field
study of four small Primary Care
practices here in Oregon
each one was analyzed independently to
try to understand the work the context
and the constraints that shaped that
word so four independent analysis
and two compare them using the output of
the first analysis to do an Apples to
Apples comparison of the four clinics
and to try to infer what does this mean
in a broader scale and then finally the
implications were designed
this study was approved by ohsu's IRB in
June
sampling once again I fall back on those
definitions we talked about first
delivering a primary care what does that
mean so I looked at Family practices
Internal Medicine Specialists that
told me that they focused on delivering
primary care so that was largely
self-reported independent and autonomous
autonomy is kind of interesting idea in
small practices independent is fairly
standard definition they're not owned by
a Hospital health system or group
practice it's a if you will a mom and
pop position practice or a small
Partnership Clinic so independent
autonomous is a little trickier because
what does that actually mean an
autonomous Clinic makes their own
decisions they choose their own
electronic health record they hire they
fire they decide what scope their
medical assistance will be allowed to do
in their practice that's what I meant by
because my goal was to find out why they
do things and in a clinic that was
forced to do things a certain way
including using somebody's somebody
else's electronic Algebra I felt that
would limit the data that I provided
collected I'm fantasized between one and
ten
small practices receive information from
multiple external sources separated
geographically we know that Health Care
is delivered in Pockets or regions or
medical laborers so a medical
neighborhood might share certain
resources a laboratory an Imaging Center
a hospital so I try to identify sites
that were distant enough that they
didn't have overlapping spheres of
healthcare resources they're all
difficult to do when it's not a
scientific process but I think by
looking at the map and spreading them
out I I accomplished that
finally I wanted to look at some sites
with and some sites without electronic
health record I was unable to recruit a
sign that was not had no I'm not help I
think I could not recruit the spelling
So I listened to neither of them have
used participate in the study now that
is a limitation of the study and I'll
address that as we get towards the map
so I found four sites enrolled them and
did a study
the data collection was done using
typical traditional qualitative research
methods including semi-structured
interviews with a written interview
guide that included written prose we
also get a lot of freeform interviewing
but they bulk of the data collections
through structured instruments
observation forms were predefined to
sort of guide my focus as I did field
observation and that became very
important given all the things to look
at and all the bright shiny objects I
wanted to explore so having an
observation form turned out to be really
critical
um again in typical qualitative research
I kept a fairly detailed notes and
drawings little notes that I would write
as I walk through the clinics Maps
diagrams sketches and reflective notes
and a Reflections were important because
as a lab technologist by training I tend
to gravitate towards ladders I
understand this so what are my biases is
to either want to hear more about lab
results or go the other direction and
not focus enough on them because I feel
I need to know more about other types of
information
so the reflective notes can help figure
out kind of where I was focusing during
days
documents and artifacts were important
cheat sheets notes a little routing
forms that they would pay per clip to a
chart anything like that photographs I
was very selective about photographs I
made sure I had the permission but there
was no Phi in the in the frame of the
photo you'll see a number of those
photos today but I didn't do a lot of
those but they were very helpful when I
was doing the analysis as a reminder for
example I had misnoted that a printer
had two trays one for lab one for other
stuff when in fact it was two separate
printers and the photograph helped
somebody with that so pilot testing was
done here at OHSU through free market
reviews several people knew they know a
day of observation upon ohsu's clinics
and one of the sites had the same EHR
that OHSU use so that turned out to be
very useful in understanding
how a large facility like OHSU might use
the same software that a small practice
producing whenever the study and then
validation was done through member
checking or sitting down with the
participants with notes and diagrams and
going through them and saying did I get
this right is this how things really
work in your clinic and of course
triangulation is looking across all of
these data types to try to see did I
misunderstand something was something
unclear or more importantly was there a
conflicting response between
participants and that happened a freedom
an M.A has one perception of how things
happened the medical records staff may
have brought to happen differently and
that didn't happen a fair amount
so how are data analyzed well I used a
method called cognitive work analysis
and that's in the title of the
presentation so it must be very
important and cognitive work analysis
came from cognitive systems engineering
specifically it came from Louisa
uh and again Rasmussen was known in a
number of different fields including
cognitive science of course engineering
design of complex systems for
controlling things like nuclear power
plants so it came from an engineering
perspective and in 1999 uh Kim Vicente
wrote a book on audience work analysis
that's kind of become that textbook for
how to communities methods but more
importantly the idea behind cognitive
work analysis is to be able to
deconstruct a complex socio-technical
domain if you will and understand it
across multiple levels of abstraction so
I'm going to say multiple levels of
abstraction a few times today and I'm
going to Define what that means in just
a moment but the idea is that I cross
not just workflow not just workflow and
Technology but I look across the entire
work system in an effort to understand
why things are done not just what is
done
your techniques used a cognitive organ
Elles especially because data collection
are
just the observations but we could also
do things like traditional task analysis
as a way of documenting the action of
workflow before as a waiter comparing it
with other science and trying to
understand why it's adaptable there are
many many approaches
and as you read some of these books on
cognitive work analysis some have six
stages some have five and that was
intentional so there's a lot of
flexibility built in the framework based
on the needs of your analysis and then
it's not widely adopted in healthcare at
least yet there was a review a scoping
review by Giancarlo that talked about
how often it's been used in healthcare
and I was really struck to find out that
few events used all five or six stages
in their copy of working classes
whether I was wise or stupid I used all
six you know
so the really this central idea behind
understanding cognitive group is this is
really illustrated by Simon's Aunt from
each these famous analogy so the
psychologist Herbert Simon basically
said you can understand the actions of
enhanced zigzagging the beach by
understanding the beach
so think of these as we work work
constraints that guide or shape how work
can be done within that domain so I was
interested not only in what our aunt was
doing but also what would be interested
like and so as we go through I think is
I this holistic approach I hope will
come through because that was really my
goal
so what is the method actually look like
again it's a very flexible flexible set
of tools that can be mixed and match
based on the needs of the analysis this
is a diagram from gather intern who's
probably done more work on applied
cognitive work analysis than a lot of
people he's not primarily an academic
but he's worked closely in some of the
Australian contingenture that have for
example on the lean Nikon who many of
you have may have approved so his
applied approach was based on academic
research having said that though we
looked at five different areas of the
work domain and very briefly because
we're not going to go through each step
today simply we don't have time the work
domain is a way of mapping the entire
Beach
work organization looks at what is the
ant actually doing now
social organization how do multiple ants
cooperate how do they exchange
information is it synchronous is it
asynchronous
work tasks what are they actually doing
within that work organization and of
course work tasks can be physical
sorting pieces of paper before I deliver
them to the provider copyright this is
interesting because as you know
cognitive work analysis seems to imply
this is focused just on cognitive work
but as it turns out just about any work
you would do in a clinic has some
Quantum developments and in clients
Crandall Klein and
one other person's book I apologize I
have it at the end uh they talk about
how Pipe Fitters do cognitive work so
don't think of cognition in terms of a
physician of making the diagnosis
although that's causing more but also a
medical assistant sorting through lab
reports and finding one that seems to be
critical is also a condimentation so the
physical and the cognitive do tend to
learn and of course automate uh I have
electronic information coming into these
practices I looked at how those are
handled this work and then finally we
look at individual strategies or
cognitive uh Pathways that individuals
or teams could use to get the work done
so that's basically the framework and
when I talk about the different stages
this is why
I talked about abstraction and I talked
about decomposition once again the idea
is to look across multiple levels of
abstraction so starting at the top
cognitive work analysis looks at the
purpose for the domain why does this
specific work system exist what is it
there to do
what values and priorities shape the
work that goes on
what is the work in abstract terms and
in very specific jobs and as we get to
the lowest level of abstraction we look
at resources what are the physical
objects in that domain what are the
types of information that come into this
domain that support the upper levels of
abstraction and note that this is also
termed a means and hierarchy simply
being that anything down here can be a
means to accomplish the ends up here so
this is the thirty thousand foot view of
the sociotechnical work domain of
information handling in requirement of
care
work itself is broken down into three
main areas work situations a situation
might be pulling a lab report off of a
printer as opposed to receiving it
electronically through an interface that
those would be different work situations
a function which we'll talk about in
some detail in just a moment and then of
course the physical cognitive and
automated tasks that actually occur in
that genre
the cognitive tasks are really based on
a lot of cognitive science I mean we're
not talking a little bit earlier about
who came first naturalistic decision
making would climb that out or
rasmussen's first idea where he came up
with something called the decision
writer so I'll leave that in the
scholars but what I find in the decision
minor which I'll walk you through in
just a moment
is that it has built in a lot of this
new cognitive science as well as the
standards such as ensley's situation
analysis so what is going on well first
of all I Define the cognitive tasks that
I wanted to focus on because I couldn't
look at everything
as key control decisions that determine
how information is passed through the
clinic so if I were a medical assistant
looking at a discharge summary how do I
decide whether that needs to be handed
to The Physician or left on the desk
those are cognitive decisions that
determine how information is handled so
that was my definition and within each
one of those the decision ladder
provides a way of looking at cues and
triggers how do I know that I need to
think through that process or do some
action what are the decision pressure
remember that situations and context is
different and people make decisions
based on context very rarely is there a
nice neat flow chart if it's this do
that hence the cognitive work became so
important at every level in a small
practice
what are the options for Action what can
I do with that information
and then plans for action so I won't go
through this but one other point about
the decision matter is is crucial which
is the idea that when people really make
decisions they use cognitive shortcuts
and those shortcuts allow you to go
uh jump straight from awareness of a
situation to an action or of course you
can do the full ladder and make a
thoughtful lengthy decision so that's
the background let's get into the
results itself
we did four cognitive work analysis I'm
not going to walk you through each of
the six stages for each of the four
sides I would love to know we're going
to go straight into name two though and
focus on the comparison and synthesis
and then include by talking about the
design application uh this is a photo of
the blue Clinic uh more on that in just
a moment a couple things to point out
the long hallway passing the medical
records area a lot of communication
occurred in that hallway this window is
where the triage nurse sat this is where
the medical record staff sat in voice
uh range of the triage first so we'll
talk about physical layout as well
so where did I do this work I mentioned
that I did four sides here in Oregon
geographically separated all of them had
an electronic health record uh three of
them had different ones two of them had
the same
the enrolled science I gave color names
to and again we want Perfection protect
their confidentiality so they are called
the purposes of the study the mileage
Clinic which is a small solar practice
in a 1 000 person rural town in southern
Atlantic Valley
the red Clinic is a Suburban Clinic here
in Portland with an M.A and an
administrator the blue Clinic is a much
larger clinic on the coast uh more on
them in a moment and then the green
Clinic is located under Columbia Gorge
and is also a government the goal of
choosing these was to get a range of
complexity geographical diversity and we
talked about the DHR so to gather the
information I spent a fair amount of
time in the field uh 20 days of field
time not include a travel time I
interviewed 24 individuals and observed
for over 40 hours now these were the
focused observations keep in mind I
spent a lot of time in the practice just
wandering around sitting in the lounge
doing opportunistic interviews
these were focused observations using
the observations
blue Clinic you talked a little bit
about their physical layout the
positioning of the triage nurse with
respect to the Natural records
they were also organized into two
sections so the architecturally they had
a West Wing they had an East wing and
their processes were somewhat different
between the two rings they actually had
somewhat different team cultures in the
two different wings
at Green Clinic that was a little bit
different even though they had four
individual wings with more providers
their processes seemed to be a bit more
socialized red Clinic of course had only
three people it had a physician a
medical assistant who was fairly new and
their office administrator was related
to the physician
and then finally by the clinic didn't
even have an M.A it was one solo Doc and
she had a part-time bookkeeper that
would come in who was a jack of all pain
she would do the scanning AMD electronic
health records you'd keep the books but
she was only there for a couple days a
week so again the goal here is to find a
diverse set of clinics to try to
understand the similarities that
difference
well these are the uh the abstractions
and the and the decompositions that
emerged from that work first of all what
is the purpose of the domain well
receive and handled external political
information to support Primary Care now
note that this was set by the design of
the site so that did not emerge from the
sites but everything below that is we're
going to talk a lot about the top values
and priorities we're going to talk about
resources but before we go there I'd
like to spend a few minutes just talking
about how they did things in the clinic
and what the implications might be
for uh factors that shape work practices
recall that there were three levels of
one practice decomposition there was the
function it was the task and the
situation so these are the four abstract
functions so we go here is not to say
how do you do things but what do you do
and what is the central focus of our
ability and both and I was influenced by
the literature review but also I really
feel like these did the absolute what
was going on in those claims so there
were four things that really were going
on the first is receiving functions or
retrieval functions get the stuff over
the phone
second was to incorporate that into the
patient record
in all four clinics that patient record
happened to be an electronic health
record it was just as happening in the
paper charts evaluated
we found three different levels of
evaluation going the first is cleaning
my non-clinical staff
they might not even know they were doing
it I take a fax off a fax machine I
notice there's a critical lab result I
know I need to do something
a lot of people would not recognize that
that process even happens and they may
try to eliminate the step of the ma or
the employment intercepting piece of
paper so we'll talk more about the
implications of taking people out of the
process in a network to stream that way
but screening turned out to be a really
important box process
triage is something I defined and I
realized triage has another clinical
meaning but here
it means that a second level provider or
a highly trained medical assistant is
doing a review of information rather
than a staff person or a clerk or the
position that your sponsor will be doing
and then finally the review step is to
provider themselves who are always
responsible for reviewing information
that comes into practice
and then finally the communication fails
communication of course can occur within
the practice and this happened by using
office email handwritten notes verbal
communication and using features within
the electronic health records as
influence of communicating between staff
providers and collectors and so forth
so there were variations that you can
and those variations first of all
including this
so if we look at these four different
functions and how those functions are
sequenced you can see hopefully a stark
difference between blue and violet
clothing with many handling paper
and red and green when they handle paper
the difference is here
in this case in sequence one
paper was received given on as documents
to the provider the provider reviewed
them on paper initial hand wrote Circle
things highlighted it and sent those
back to medical records or to their
clerks where they were incorporated into
the electronic health scanner
meanwhile we've read a red Clinic
they were Incorporated initially upon
receiver so everything went through in
green Clinic the medical records folks
they would incorporate it into the
electronic health record and the
provider who evaluated within the EHR
no
many times they would print out the
document to review so it would come in
on a paper they would be incorporated
into the HR and then for reasons that
we'll talk about them we could print it
out of it
so that's a little bit about work
sequencer there were other situations
that vary of course the information
sources varying the medium of paper
electronic rule
urgency and meaning
medical records people often knew that
something was expected if a provider had
been asking me all week where are those
records I asked for when they come in
I'm going to be aware of that I'm going
to remember it and I'm probably going to
handle it can provide it so the need was
also there
urgency
um as a lab tech I have been calling
critical results for years that didn't
really happen a lot we were dealing with
primary care practices there weren't a
lot of critical results so frankly the
verbal communication
became outside providers was fairly
minimal and then of course time of day
all of the practices offered extended
hours
and staff index do I have a registered
nurse that's capable of doing a tree
option so all of those Define the
situations that thus drove the work
practices
so we will go through every one of these
but you can see the variation across
clinics between how they receive paper
information electronic converting
this tiny oops this tiny little clinic
only received information on paper but
they have just licensed a standalone
vaccine you know we haven't applied that
server that did not integrate an
electronic health record so it was
interesting watching them sort of play
with it and see how that was really
improved with their workflow
Mets interfaces three of the four had at
least one laboratory results interface
that sent structured data into the
electronic health record
two of them had more than one
and then portals portals as you know are
external access points that are either
regional health information exchanges
although none of my sites use that but
they wanted I forced into the health
systems electronic health where they had
selective access to either their own
patients or through a function called
break the glass they could get at other
patients but had that documenting that
they've reviewed these records so these
portals potentially gave them a huge
amount of information outside of their
practice that if there is only a click
away
in practice because they have no way of
knowing what's out there what might be
out for me
it's efficient expression unless the
patient tells you I was admitted to
Providence I'm not going to go with the
Providence plural on the off chance that
there's something in there so while this
is a valuable source of information the
usage was not what I would have expected
it was to be
and so we won't go through all of these
but I think you can see that there's a
pretty wide variety in the types of
information and the methods used to
receive that information
this is the I think Paul calls this the
describing the schematic of a 747. so
I'm just going to point out a couple of
the features
in the incorporation is function we're
talking about getting stuff into the
patient rack again if it was paper chart
it would be apply themselves in the case
of the electronic health record there
are basically five or six ways if you
get stuck in it so we're going to start
by talking about scanning now scanning
was done in different ways at different
places and the main difference seemed to
be whether I could scan directly into
the elect health record or if I had to
go through an intermediate software
package called a document management
system blue Clinic was the only one with
the document management system notice
that OHSU uses the same document
management system in the medical record
store so their workflow in a small
Clinic was essentially based on what we
would do at a large Health System
this presented some issues first of all
the inspection and preparation was more
rigorous for the document management
system because the document management
system
with barcodes so if we're ordering a
document to be scanned they had little
pieces of white tape that they would
clip out and paste over barcodes to keep
it from both confusing the scan
so preparation wasn't just about visual
inspection does this look good
our pages in this thing it's actually
looking at the content itself and making
sure that it will be cleaning the scan
and then moving over here we get into a
number of other terms matching indexing
naming and signing and I'll draw your
attention to one Gap here we have the
option to assign a scanned document to a
provider so it shows up in your inbox
that occurred at reading read and by the
clinic
over here that option was not available
through the mechanism other document
management system they did not have the
option of sending things to a physician
inbox
could that have been one of the reasons
they chose to scan later review first in
fact it was the timing was very
important the providers wanted to see
the paper because they knew this was a
lengthy process and once it was in the
document management system they still
could not see it in the electronic
alphabet so it's essentially a two-step
process rather than the one-step process
so I could go on about scanning but that
turned out to be a far more elaborate
process that would be
indexing well as you know indexing is
filing stuff and in the paper chart
there's a long history of paper chart
organization you've got your tabs and
tabs usually laboratory Radiology
Hospital people kind of know what to
expect on a paper chart this is an
actual paper chart that they've archived
in one of the sites
in the electronic health record on the
government it's a little trickier for a
number of reasons first of all in many
electronic health records whether this
is how they were designed by the vendor
or how they were implemented by the
implementer there are different category
category tabs or buckets that scan
documents can be moved so the active
indexing wasn't just getting it into the
EHR it was figuring out which bucket to
put it in and in the case of Blue Clear
there were 34 subcategories and 11
categories of where to put stuff
and as the provider or the M.A looking
for those data how do I know where they
are so you can see the handwriting on
here
they've been live on their EHR for a
little over a year and continue to
move a chart because of confusion
because the mental model of where things
should be in the electronic health
record was different than where medical
records people were putting things so
work in progress
another thing is to name it so where it
goes to the chart is important but you
can also put a short label on an
electronic document and that shows up in
the document lists in the document trees
green Clinic had a formal process with a
procedure of how they name their
document
and this is a case of a culture where
they would type in the type of culture
date positive negative and so on so that
when the provider of the ma saw that in
a list they not only do what it was but
they had some idea of what was
appearance this is a human adding
metadata to a document to make it easier
to find
now I don't know if somebody taught them
to do this if they came across this
themselves but neat idea and they're
probably these folks probably could have
done the same thing
now I mentioned there are many many ways
to incorporate information into the
American record factors
two of the sites had a operational fact
server by the clinic had a factor where
they were just kind of breaking in but
the idea is that the faxes come are sent
by the source as effects but they come
in electronically and they sit on a
server somewhere as a fax payment so
what happens next well first of all
unlike the fax machine I can't hear or
see a fax
it's sitting in electronic USA so I have
to be able to access that security to
see what's in them second
all of the sites had one batch number
which means everything's dumped into the
same bucket including sandwich orders
from the shop down the street so part of
the function of the medical records
person was to go through this fax queue
and get rid of spam faxes and figure out
what was important and what was it
again it indexed it they named it and
often went into the electronic health
record
so that was that server interface is
again Limited at least in the sites I
went to to laboratory results and
Radiology results uh coming in from
outside
so there are several different uh
factors that came in we talked about
assignment but also matching and the
automated cognitive process in the
tablet
try to determine is this the right
patient
is this the right provider and should I
link this to an order now there were
implications of not linking factors or
not linking electronic orders or results
to an order
recall that I placed an order for a lab
test in the EHR it has a status I'd like
to be able to look at that status and
see if the result is better if this
matching goes wrong that doesn't happen
and if there were cases where one
particular lab would not hyphenate
patient names
the interface would throw it out when I
came back and sit in a orphan file and
have to be manually recognized
well one site had a practice for
routinely checking informal privacy
relationship so again you can see that
cognitive functional impacts automation
as well as humans and then finally
evaluation we talked about for horses
some other ways of getting information
into the electronic health record
included entry or dictation use of
special EHR account for example a
telephone account or documentary
manifold and then cutting and pasted
from the portal which was used very very
rarely the uh some positions like using
it most did not and will simply
summarize what they saw in the portal in
their clinical Network
we talked about screenings we talked
about triage so I'm going to move on
from there
because I'm running a lot of time and
then finally communication is the fourth
function and we talked about three
different areas of communication
internal communication using notes email
level communication but also patient
notification and as you can imagine
there are several different ways that
could be done the preference was to do
it in person either over the telephone
or the medical assistant would call a
patient or in a subsequent visit with
the provider
if it were a critical test result they
may or may not be qualification it was
based on judgment and this also reflects
what comes in the literature
procedures for calling test results to
patients who largely ad hoc and in many
cases dependent on they know news is
good news approach
now in patient engagement that's
probably not going to fly anymore only
two sites had a patient portable in
their electronic health record to
provide electronic access but again that
was selected the provider had to choose
to release certain information to the
form and at least in the towns that I
went to because they were largely small
and Rural the uptake of the portal was
actually the low people didn't seem to
refinement value
so what about mail was another one
um mail was not often used this is an
example of a mailer card where they
would hand write the results in a path
and mail it uh why postage fees
it's not something I would think of in
terms of a shaping factor for doing
information management but it was
so what explains this practice variation
well we introduced you
to abstraction and the decomposition
to talk about purpose but what about the
values and priorities and what about the
individual resources that determine how
the processes we're just talking about
but we'll begin at the top most abstract
part of the hierarchy external
priorities well laws and regulations
obviously the I think the most sales
example is using fax machine do I hit
one
so I've been told that the medical
industry is probably the last Bastion of
fat sickles but here we are they all
have Max machines they all have to use
them standards of care still for
practice in the state of Oregon am I
allowed to have a medical assistant with
a no formal training review a test
result we screen it before passing it on
to me contractual obligations two of the
sites had recently been recognized as
patient-centered medical homes one of
them was part of an Accountable Care
Organization CCM
that had contractual requirements for
handling information suddenly they cared
a lot more about tracking and pending
orders about communicating results to
patients
community and patient expectations it's
all well and good that I have a
relationship with the hospital next door
so I don't expect to get discharge
summaries from the big hospital down the
road well that's not what the patient
expects the patient expects providers to
communicate regardless of their
organizational preferences or
information
and so on business
business was huge I mentioned stamps
being just one small example
but business factors the scientific
Columbia Gorge was fairly well off they
weren't struggling they were a beautiful
practice with art on the worlds
the coast practice was in a small town
that had been just decimated by a loan
crash
poor patient population an older
building is well maintained it was
lovely but it was an older building the
point is that they had business concerns
that drove how they did work how many
patients did they need to see per day
was it an issue that Dr Smith would
spend four hours working my notes every
night instead of seeing patients yes so
again business constraints also
determine how they would approach doing
the foreign
and then finally individual preferences
and priorities I mentioned the position
that would spend four hours doing now
it's why
because she believed that's the right
way to do clinical
sit down and write about them and you
don't click a few things on the template
and then send the patient out of the
exam room and close the account
this is
something I really like though was a
blue Clinic because of the I think the
patient-centered medical home which was
a fairly recent development they posted
six values along that back Hollow where
the staff would drop as a reminder it's
a way of essentially emphasizing their
organizational culture that hey this is
what we hear about
otherwise though as you can imagine
getting at values getting a part of
these through interviews and certainly
through observation was very difficult
to do and I'll talk about that as an
interesting study
physical constraints what we touched on
many many of these are examples
obviously the source
can the laboratory send an electronic
test result first of all can I afford to
buy the interface these interfaces by
the way to go anywhere from fifteen to
thirty thousand dollars per air base and
off of the lab will meet the cost of
that but only if you send me enough lab
work to make it work in a while so I'm
constrained financially
by what uh by what uh Labs can send me
electronic regulation
limitations and affordances more on that
in just a moment contact
one thing I can do not focus on
intentionally was the reform the
structure the actual representation of
information either on the screen or on
paper I consider it basically a blob of
stuff and I followed it through the
process in future studies I would like
to look more at the representation and
the actual content in the moment so
again I won't list out all of these but
hopefully we've touched on Staffing
Staffing of people technical
capabilities and then of course human
backups and the ability to deal with
interruptions attention all of these
were comfortable environments working
they were well lit
but they may not have themselves there
might be practices out there that might
feel like sweatshops
so what if the design implications uh
home stretch we have three more slides
to go
well first of all what is design I am
not a designer I'm not trained as a
designer although if I took borrow a
doctor whose courses would be someday I
appreciate it
so these are just my Impressions from
looking at how processes work and having
existing paper and electronic systems
supported the abstract and concrete
activities
so first of all what would you want to
do well with any technology or process
you'd want to make things more efficient
more effective reduce or eliminate
errors certainly enhanced worker comfort
and satisfaction make it more pleasant
to do that how frustrating is it to know
that there's a scanned document and
click and click and click and not be at
the point and then support and encourage
adaptive activity and I mentioned that
Gavin Linton was sort of the applied
approach that I used he would use that
term to really bring us back to this
idea that we have a beach we have his
hands and the constraints on that beach
really shapes what my options as a
worker are and shaving uh how I do
things so if I were talking to the
designer and they said what did you
learn in four Pro Primary Care practices
that I could I could take home and be
able to use my designs my answer would
be first of all look for four reasons
which implies by the way go and work
you're not going to get this from
reading a procedure manual or
interviewing one or two subject matter
experts you've got to be in the
environment you've got to see
this is an affordance I have multiple
displays set up on my desktop I can open
the electronic health record I can open
the portal I can do things back and
forth
this is a visual cue by stacking up
pieces of paper I can see essentially a
real-time cue and a status of how much
work I have to do that is a very thick
chart that's going to be the amount of
work usually
these are the two printers I may have
mentioned before notice the blue paper
blue paper for lab results white paper
for everything else and then of course
the inbox paper gets put in a slot I
hear people being put in my slot I'm not
aware that there's something wrong so
when we automate these processes do I
replace these affordances with something
else something similar something general
situation awareness again getting back
to ensley's thought that we have
reception of something we have an
understanding of that and then we can
project into the future what that means
so how do we support or enhance it well
first of all make information stays
visible
with a stack of charts sitting on the
table that's a visible State it's
sitting there it's in the pile for me to
review I know I need to go look at that
but when you automate it and you put it
in these little cues or these little
folders or these little Jelly Bean
bubbles in the electronic health record
that light up when there's any lab
results it's a different form of
perception to try to keep up on this
monitor provide feedback uh no one
really monitored how often things were
linked for Laboratories or how often a
Specialists failed to send a specialty
report
ensure automated tasks are transparent
this was huge one of the features I got
pretty excited about was a automatic
overdue result
bucket so you look at the EHR and
there's this big tab there and it says
overview results and you click on it
there's stuff in there why don't you use
this this is fantastic answer I don't
know why things go in there
when I look at them it doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense and so we
don't use it
so the transparency was not there they
didn't understand what the EHR was doing
by putting things into those buckets and
dust they were probably missing out on
what could be a useful feature
I'm highlighting relevant and context
appropriate information really stressing
the idea contest
um our approach is to put more and more
information on screens to basically try
to give them everything there either on
the screen or a few clicks away the idea
though if they need
actually
and we won't go through all of those but
true
worker adaptation and this gets into
really sort of the conclusion uh that
Kim Vicente was saying which is to let
the worker finish the design so the
design can only go so far but the worker
really needs to be able to modify these
tools so it works best in their
environment so how do we do that well
first of all certain tasks may add value
in unexpected ways the uh the clerk
pulling a fax and looking doing this
informal screening function that adds
value because if I take that away it
sits in the inbox until the provider is
done for the day until they're in
between patients until they can log on
and see it so it adds a point where I
can hash things and in systems in
engineering we would call that loose
couple that a tightly coupled system
doesn't have many opportunities to
intervene a Loosely coupled system how
long it becomes of course there are pros
and consoles individuals organize in a
similarly different
by some providers that would again print
out things from a portal spread them out
on the desk to use multiple monitors so
the way they would assimilate
information is very difficult
different mental models we touched on
this with the organization of the paper
chart versus how the electronic health
record was set up especially with
respect to the endocuments roles and
responsibilities and small practices the
investment records both in one practice
also covered for telephones in the
middle classes they were very
specialized and stated minimum
and I am
done
thank you James
uh he invites your questions
James thank you excellent business
um early on we were talking about your
methodology and cognitive work analysis
can you make a comment that
um most of the if not all of the other
authors that you have read and not used
all five or six stages that you chose to
do that I was wondering what you're
thinking was behind that and and why you
thought it was important to
I think they had a much narrower Focus
so I was looking at a complete
socio-technical system and the framework
really described all of them so that was
mindful if I were doing a design project
or say
um I don't know setting up a crash card
in ICU that made me Focus just on one or
two stages because that gives us enough
information
so it really comes down to is we would
say the research question or the purpose
of the analysis thank you
um now you mentioned you used uh
you know your cognitive work analysis to
look at that complex socio-technical
system I was can you mentioned that it
was a tool boxer a cartoon of analysis
technique so I was wondering
um
what aspects of that people once you
come before what aspects you didn't
if you can speak to that a little bit
yeah I I think
I was misled in a way but I read the
Chantix book you said it's right up
front this is not a couple this is a
framework this is not a set of methods
um I didn't quite take that to heat I
thought I could read enough and
basically have a methodology cognitive
work analysis doesn't work out it
provides a structure of a scaffolding
that you can insert methods and
if we go back to this hierarchy the
ideas that I can use different data
collection and Analysis methods to fill
in each one of these rows and I'll say
this now that in future work I could use
culture surveys interviews a more
Advanced Techniques to really try to
understand the values and priorities I
don't think I got there in this study
and then uh also in terms of
cognitive forecasts
um again I part of my method was based
on cognitive task analysis and being
able to walk people through their mental
reasoning but that wasn't the main focus
on the interviews and I think I missed
out on one of richness so to answer your
question I think the methods can be
mixed and matched and inserted in the
scaffolding a cognitive work analysis
doesn't tell you what you used to say um
just add on to that are there any
particular analysis techniques or
representations that you found useful
and computers that you didn't uh the
decision lab originally I found a
hernativity because it is it's a complex
representation but after reading more
and slate on situation awareness really
understanding why this was important
everywhere I looked I could see cues and
triggers I could see people evaluating
external information to make decisions
and I can also see decision shortcuts so
for example Dr Smith always wants the
full charge scanned when it's received
from an outside Source stuff in terms
those are rules so the decision I think
turned out to be an important structure
I will tell you I did not create a
diet plan for every single control task
and you need to once I understood the
framework I can apply that in tabular
form that will just try is that kind of
person
the abstraction decomposition hierarchy
this right here I I've grown too much
I'm really going through
yeah what about those Maps into the
tools that you've done used because
yeah
uh what Paul's talking about is when I
get the number check and when I went
back into the clinic to make sure I
understood what was really going on the
way I did that was to draw these happy
little maps and then use color coding
to use color coding it was real hard to
see but basically to spread out this is
how papers handle this is how verbal
communication is handled and we walked
through this with multiple particles of
this so I picked this up from
observation from interviews then I went
back on the second visit I don't think I
mentioned that I visited each site twice
the second visit was all about going
through these maps of the clinic and
trying to make sure I understood the
physical flow of information
there's one question it I'm James
McKenna can you speak a bit more to any
unexpected danger she noted regarding
mimicking the hospital like the doc
management system
wow
um
one of the applications of cognitive
work analysis is to do a failure mode
and effects type analysis a more
engineering type Focus where you're
looking at where things go wrong that
wasn't the study I did I will tell you
there were many uh many times where I
saw things get misplaced where I heard
conversations where is this where is
that this should we be back by now I
couldn't see anything dangerous
so uh it's hard to say keep in mind
though that I was only in the clinics
for a small amount of time
I was focused on looking at certain
workflows and more importantly
they were probably protective about what
they let me hear I have a researcher
walking around with a couple so the
short answer is I don't know if there
any really hazardous situations if I
ever seen them I didn't I did see many
many cases
custom literature or things would get
lost and displaced I would expect
something to come back in our list
so um
if any tweets and that answer me yeah
judged I did a lot of examination of the
social systems as well
um I'm curious when you were
interviewing uh your subject from
different sites did you find that there
might have been through the process of
triangulation that the perceptions of
the people within the clinics may have
been discordant or was there any
evidence change between one clinic or
the other and if so did that have an
implication to believe for their shared
situation where I'm sure there's shared
times across worried and how they how
well or not with the function
um yes I definitely found this gorgeous
information across multiple participants
within the same site
so uh for example when I first
interviewed uh The Physician at Vet
Clinic he said everything comes in
electronics everything's electronic
company find out that the an admin is
sitting the front desk scanning the
perception was different it's electronic
to the provider and it's not
electronically administrative system so
there were a lot of discordant things uh
there are also differences in opinion
the medical records people had an idea
of how that chart should be organized
and they probably had some say when they
set up the electronic health labor let
those categories might be
provide or something other hand they've
gotten used to them by now they kind of
knew where to look for things they would
not have done that
so again whether it's constraint of the
vendor making it that way or whether
it's how it's set up you know
that was to school looking across sites
I medical records people the two sites
that had full-time medical records staff
by the way a Maine Clinic had two people
new Clinics of two people
even though they did rotate between
phones and some other areas they thought
of themselves as the stewards of the
medical record and so they had an
ownership that was very interesting
there was one comment when the one
doctor that made a vacation would send
the dictation out to somebody they know
in the community it would come back in a
meeting and it'll be pasted into an
interim electronic Healthcare
fundamental Recreation now we'll see
that interesting why do you do that no
one else can do it
she really thought that was their
quality would suffer if somebody else
did tasting anything
so does that give you some examples
thank you James May I see those
acknowledge words no I think James is
really showing all the signs of being a
true academic he loves to talk about his
work
let's give him a hand
thank you
go ahead well thank you very much of
course uh thank you to my committee to
John Ashford couldn't be here today at
all my committee members special thanks
to gather winter and I'm Australia who
let you sit in on these courses did a
great help to me
um all the clinics that let me uh watch
and and spend time with them demise
obviously the faculty the staff here do
mice my family friends Magdalene of
course and a long list of people that
really gave us a lot of time for a
generously a lot of these names you may
recognize I didn't think I was going to
get Hardeep Singh on the phone to talk
about my work he was more than happy to
do that so all of these people were in
medicine and with that I was thinking oh
and thank you to the nlm and then the
funding for three years on my team yeah
all right
thank you all for coming uh you're all
excused now someone who can uh Good Deed